He is revered as one of the greatest artists of all time.
For centuries is typifying into the perfect artistic genius.
His greatest legacy is the surviving works that we can see today.
The Sistine Chapel,
the statue of David,
yet behind the artworks law is a complex and stubborn man,
and in this week's biographics,
we go beyond the facade to discover the real Michael Angelo,
Italy in the 15th century.
It was very different to the country that we know today.
Back then,
it was a collection of small republics.
These city states were all under the governorship of the pope who was located in
Rome.
The key republics were Florence,
Genoa,
and Venice.
Every state I didn't.
Certain governors,
it's nobles,
peasants,
priests,
imams,
government officials nestled in the remote app and nine mountains of central
Italy was the small village of Capri seat.
It was here on March the sixth,
14,
75.
The Franciscan Deniro,
Buena Rossi gave birth to her second son,
Michelangelo,
her husband's a lot of etsy.
Does.
Leonardo,
we are not used to.
Mooney was a lonely official who had the job of convicting and sentencing
criminals when baby Michael Angelo was six months old,
the family of four moved to Florence here,
a lot of Itso,
so bought a small farm near the village of set.
In your note,
it was in this village and the child spent his early years under the care of
wetness farming off newborns do a wetness for the first few years of life was a
common practice at that time.
The women who took in Michelangelo was married to a stone cutter in later years
when he had transformed himself into a sculptor.
Michelangelo commented that he had drunk model dust with his nurses milk when he
was three.
Michelangelo returned to live with this family in Florence.
The family was poor rams with new babies arriving frequently.
The household was overcrowded.
A lot of ECO received a migo government salary,
and his farm wasn't very successful.
In fact,
he believed that the work of a lowly farmer was beneath him when he was six
years of age,
young Michelangelo's tough life got even tougher.
His mother died leaving behind five young sons,
including a newborn.
Ludovico,
did his best working two jobs and still managing to trundle the boys off to mass
at the Church of Santa Croce and Florence every Sunday.
This church was filled with magnificent works of art,
including a crucifix carved by the famous sculptor,
Donatello and wall paintings by he auto,
one of the greatest artists of all time.
The young Michelangelo must have marveled at these magnificent pieces.
In 1485,
a lot of ego took a new wife,
lucrezia deadly eldine.
Gagliano came from a rich family bringing 600 floor into the union as a dowery.
This was an enormous amount at the time and it flips to the fortunes of the
family overnight and immediate result of the family's newfound wealth was that a
lot of ego was able to afford to send as Michelangelo to a Latin school to learn
reading,
writing,
and mathematics,
but boy soon proved that he was no academic boards with his lessons.
He would stare out of the window while doodling on paper.
However,
one thing he did fall in love with was poetry,
returning home for vacation,
Michelangelo,
he told his father that he was more interested in art than in academic studies,
but a lot of ego was not impressed at that time.
Artists were the lowly paid servants of noblemen being considered less or more
than a servant's Ludovico wanted his son to aspire to.
More than that,
the only person who seemed to understand Michelangelo's passion for us was an
older boy that he had befriended by the name of Francisco Gren Artsy Francisco
himself was a budding artist apprentice do the famous artists,
Dominica,
girl,
and diary.
He took them Michelangelo to his Master's workshop and showed him works in
progress.
The younger boy was mesmerized by what he saw.
He knew that being an artist was his destiny.
Despite his father's negativity,
Michelangelo kept begging to be allowed to pursue his passion.
Meanwhile,
his friend Francisco encouraged him to produce some drawings,
which he showed to his master Galleon dire.
The great artist was impressed and expressed the desire to also take
Michelangelo on.
There's an apprentice.
Finally,
lots of ECO relented under the age of 12.
His son became apprentice to gallon diode the most around the most successful
artists workshop in Florence along with his two brothers.
They were kept busy decorating chapters in Florence.
The brothers had a number of apprentices aged between eight and 15 who lived
with them and assisted with paintings and murals.
The parents,
including Ludovico,
had to pay for living expenses and for training from the Ugandans your brothers
young Michael Angelo learns how to prepare a wooden panel for painting and how
to plaster a wall in preparation for the painting of a fresco.
He was also taught how to make working drawings called cartoons,
which would form the basis of finished paintings
among the apprentices.
Michelangelo was an immediate standout.
Still.
He proved to be stubborn and it's quite full of himself.
He was given the task of copying works previously drawn by his master and having
done so declared that his works were better than the originals gallons.
I acknowledged that the boy had great talent,
but he was angered by his pride for attitude.
They also saw that Michelangelo lacked the patients needed to learn some of the
skills required such as painting frescoes.
He showed little interest in grinding and mixing paints,
and couldn't be bothered mixing the ingredients needed for the smooth plaster
needed for fresco painting when he was 14,
Michelangelo went one step too far.
He had copied some drawings that his master had done of women,
but then he did to correct some finer aspects of the originals by going over
them with a broad NIB pen.
This was too much gallons.
Io kicked Michelangelo out of the workshop claiming that there was no teaching
this no at all.
Rather than being discouraged,
the talented team made the decision that paints and pasta went off for him.
He considered them to be a lesser form of art to him.
The real skill lay in stone producing fine sculptures of the human form.
This desire would take them to the very pinnacle of Florentine Ability.
The house of Medici
before Michelangelo had been dismissed by Gulen diode,
some members of the Medici family visited the workshop.
Among them was an elderly sculptor named Beto.
Did Giovanni.
This man,
notice the talents that Michelangelo possessed and struck up a relationship with
a boy.
Often his dismissal.
The budding young sculpture sought out the old man,
but older was employed by Lorenzo de Medici,
the most powerful man in the city.
He was making statues,
medals for the man and looking after his art collection.
Many of Lorenzo statues were displayed in a golden artists.
Went to drawer and carve.
This area was a gathering place for students,
sculptors who would get feedback and instruction from a whole day about their
work.
Soon,
Michelangelo was a regular in the garden.
The now 15 year old began creating sculptures from clay and bringing them to the
garden.
They was younger than the other.
Budding is.
His skill was clearly beyond this.
This lead to jealousy sometimes and even lead to physical violence in one
encounter.
Michelangelo,
even at his nose broken that the boy he was not deterred begging a piece of
marble from another sculptor.
He created his first relief carving the head of a foreign just as he had been
hoping.
This sculpture was seen by Lorenzo de Medici who was immediately taken with the
boys skill.
He brought Michelangelo into his fold,
giving him his own room and paying him an allowance.
The young artist's life was now more peaceful.
He was able to settle down to the task of perfecting his chosen art form.
One of his first major projects was to convert a scene from mythology on model
as a relief panel.
This was the battle of the centaurs.
These creatures with the heads and arms of men and the bodies of horses gave him
plenty of scope to show action and form.
The realism and gentle precision of this work is remarkable for a sculptor of
such a young age.
The other major piece that Michelangelo produced while working in the house of
Medici was a relief panel called Madonna of the steps.
It shows the Virgin Mary nursing the infant Jesus.
The piece is carved on fine white model and shows the madonnas face in profile
as she holds her infant son against her.
Things were going remarkably well for the 17 year olds and he was living in the
inner sanctum of the richest family in the city and he had a powerful patron who
admired his talents.
Unfortunately,
it wasn't the last.
In April 14,
92,
Lorenzo suddenly died.
His son pro took over,
but he can't let off a sculpture.
He gave Michelangelo no work until the winter when you decided that he would
like a snowman made.
He ordered Michelangelo to make one.
It would prove to be the artists strangest condition.
Around the same time the prior of Santo Spirito asked the young sculptor to a
crucifix for his church to license with the results of the prior gave Michael
Angelo the use of a room in which he could work.
He was able to dissect corpses in order to study anatomy.
The idea behind this was,
of course,
to make the most lifelike sculptures of the human body possible.
He believed that in order to know how to make these sculptures,
he had to know how the human body was put together.
The US.
He actually became one of the first.
People do dissect and study.
The human body in this way,
by 1494,
Florence was facing a crisis and army lads buying King Charles the eighth of
France was it the walls and was threatening to overrun the city.
Many people,
including Michelangelo,
fled the city.
He traveled to the Lanya in northern Italy and Venice and important trading
city.
Michelangelo.
He hoped to find work.
However,
he could not find any employment,
so he went back to behlen.
Yeah,
nothing lost his patron.
Michelangelo set out in search of a replacement.
He found it in the form of San Francisco,
outer vandy or your local Nobel and politician.
I'll prevent the set,
his talented new sculpture to the task of carving the missing fingers of the
unfinished,
trying of send them Monica in the church at the same name again.
Michael Angelo,
now 20 had fallen on his feet.
He enjoyed a comfortable home,
had stone and supplies provided and received commissions for his artwork.
Just as it happens in Florence.
This bred resentment among other sculptors.
They paid rent,
sports tools since stone and survived out of their own pockets.
Meanwhile,
back in Florence,
a change of power had a cut.
A priest by the name of [inaudible] Savonarola had instigated a fierce campaign
against the house of Medici.
When the threats of French invasion hurt emerged,
the house of Medici had fled.
The city leaving Savonarola for you to take power.
This strict churchmen disapproved of paintings and sculptures that showed the
naked human body.
As a result,
prospects were not good for local sculptors.
However,
in 1495,
Michelangelo felt a great urge to our town,
to Florence to see his family.
While then he made contact with some members of the house of see now living
under false names,
one of them Lorenzo DPF,
Francisco de Medici wanted Michael Angelo to help him sell a statute that he had
made earlier.
It was a figure of the Roman God of Love Cupid.
If the statue was aged to look like an ancient statue,
Lorenzo reasons,
it would make a lot of money in Rome.
Michelangelo is smeared the statue with deaths to make it look as if it had been
buried.
Even took the forge dan deep to Rome,
where it was purchased by a senior judgment calls and our re Reo.
While in room Michael,
Angela was introduced to some powerful people,
including members of the board,
your family who numbered among them the pope,
and he was well aware that Michelangelo was really the creator of cupids quickly
commissioned him to create another statue for his collection.
The statue that resulted has come to be recognized as Michelangelo's
masterpiece,
the statue of Bacchus,
the Greek god of wine and celebrations.
Yes.
Although everyone else was impressed,
the cardinal was not.
He thought of the Gods looked too drunk and refuse to pay for the work.
Michael Angelo now had to fight to get paid for a job that he had already
completed.
On top of this,
he received news that his father had fallen into bad financial straits.
What do you need it and fast.
It was a new patron to support not just himself,
but also his family.
For several months,
nothing seemed to pan out for the 21 year old master sculptor.
He was without a patron.
He was without payments for his back,
his statue,
and just follow the was in desperate need of financial assistance.
Then in November of 14,
97 things to contend for the best at,
it was conditioned to produce an exciting new work by a French ambassador by the
name of Cardinal Zone.
Bill had to like grow that and envisioned a statue of the Virgin Mary cradling
the dead Jesus subject known as the piano.
It took Michael Angelo two years to complete the theater,
but it was worth it.
The finished work was displayed in the Vatican and everyone who saw it was
amazed at the realism of the flesh and fabric that the sculptor had fashioned
from the cold model.
The psm made Michelangelo's famous now the most powerful men in Europe who were
clamoring to have him work for them.
It seemed as if as money,
whereas we're finally behind him
back in Florence,
the scene have changed once again on a railroad.
The priesthood fallen into disfavor and it's been executed.
It.
It was now safe for artists to return and to pursue projects that the
authorities of the Florentine Cathedral,
the guns of,
formulates the idea to commission a giant statue of the biblical killer of
Goliath,
young David to sculptors had already been commissioned to do the job.
Both had failed,
merely managing to make the huge block of marble almost unusable in 50.
No one.
The job was given to Michelangelo in order to do the job,
these sculptor had to stop working on another job in Romans,
relocate to Florence.
This blessing from one project to another became a common practice and one that
created frequence legal ramifications.
The creation of Davis was an immensely challenging and lengthily Joel.
The first decision was to choose the pose that fitted in with the way the marble
had already been worked.
This prevented him from emulating the traditional pose,
which showed David standing with Goliath had his feet,
so therefore he decided to do depict David's in the moments before the fight,
as if it was looking upon his phone.
His next move was to surround the huge piece of marble with barricades.
Then you went to work.
He tirelessly chipped away at the giant.
Three years later,
the statue of David was completed.
It was a triumph with crowds lavishing praise on the creator of the 14 foot nude
figure.
The man who had commissions,
the work pro to arena and ruler of Florence was also impressed that he told
Michael Angelo the David's nodes was do brought the sculptors.
Stubborn pride now came to the but it was tempered with common sense,
taking a handful of marble dust.
He climbed up the scaffolding and pretended to chisel the nose,
even let the dust falls to the ground.
Soderini declared that the nose was now much better
in 50,
93,
a new Pope Julius.
The second was elected in Rome.
Julius had great artistic ambitions and he knew who he wanted to spearhead the
many projects he had in mind,
and this of course was Italy's greatest sculptors.
Michelangelo,
Michelangelo had the skills needed to do justice to the greats.
Theocratic works that the pope and visions Julius knocked down the unstable
fifth century basilica of Saint Peter's and the Vatican,
and it's began rebuilding the chapter on a much grander scale.
The centerpiece was to be his own tomb,
which would be designed and carved by Michelangelo.
This massive project was intended to show the greatness of Julia says both the
Pope and also as a patron of the arts.
It was to be three stories high and covered in life size sculptures.
The sculptures spent the first eight months just querying the marble needed for
the projects.
It would prove to be his most frustrating project,
one on which he would work on and off for the next 40 years.
In the end of the finished tomb was smaller than plans,
but still vast.
Only three of the statues were by Michelangelo,
the large bearded Moses and the biblical characters of Rachel and Leah,
and instead of being placed in some pizzas,
it was put in the much less grands.
Church of San Pietro.
Four years into the tomb projects,
Pope Julia set his sights on the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel in the Vatican.
The ceiling was painted with a pattern of gold stars,
but the pope envisions something far grander.
Even though Michelangelo was known as a sculptor and painter,
the pope chose him to do the work.
The great sculptor had not worked on a fresco since his days as an apprentice
back in Florence bars back in the day when the pope chose you for a job,
you did it,
but that did not mean that you have to do it willingly.
Michelangelo,
he considered himself to be a slave to the whims of the pope.
He wrote a balance of the painting project.
This is not my profession.
I am wasting my time and all for nothing they got helped me.
It was a massive job.
The chapel ceiling covered a curved surface of about 5,600 square feet.
That's 507 square meters.
In addition,
these ceiling has an uneven surface and it was 60 feet above the chapels floor.
The pope commissioned the artist to fill this canvas with scenes from the Old
Testament's.
Michelangelo plans out name,
scenes taken from the book of Genesis.
The centerpiece would be the creation of Adam for for pain staking years.
Michelangelo worked on the ceiling.
It was backbreaking work.
The figures were designed to be seen from the floor,
but the artists had to paint high up on the scaffolding lying on its back.
According to his official biographer on dv,
he works on his own,
applying the plaster,
mixing the colors,
and doing all the painting,
the results.
They were breathtaking.
The use of perspective and the dramatic rendition of the figures were admired by
everyone who saw them.
Having triumphantly completed the assisting chapel project.
Michelangelo returns to his work on the tube of Julius when Pope Julius died in
15.
13.
The urgency I went out to the projects in 15,
17,
the new pope,
Leo the 10th asked Michelangelo to design a new facade for the Church of San
Lorenzo in Florence.
There we had no experience.
That's an architect's.
The sculptor was confident that he could do a good job.
He throw himself into the projects,
buying a piece of land near the church in order to work on his facade,
but then in 15,
20,
the project was put on hold and then cancel altogether.
Michelangelo,
he was furious.
He had invested himself fully,
both physically and financially into the project.
Partly to placate him,
the pope gave him a replacement projects the MEDICI tombs to be created in
remembrance of two members of the family who had died prematurely.
Michelangelo began work on the Medici Chapel and 50 19 two,
which was added to the library a few years later.
Both buildings took years to complete and are stunning designs.
The artist was now at the height of his creative power,
but crisis was just around the corner.
In 15,
27 armies from France and the holy Roman Empire invaded Italy.
Rome was looted and burned by now.
There was yet another pope,
claimants the seventh,
and he sided with the holy Roman Empire.
When it besieged Florence,
a loyal Florence,
Michelangelo returns home to defend this city.
He set to work designing new fortifications to help protect the city.
That's his efforts were in vain.
After a long struggle,
the city fell with many people being killed.
Michelangelo,
he went into hiding,
concealing himself in a tiny crypt onto the ultra.
If the Medici Chapel in Santa Renzo very states until the news came through that
the pope had no animosity against him.
Michelangelo spends his latter years writing poetry and continuing to work for
the pope's in Rome.
One of his most famous poems describes how uncomfortable he was when painting
the Sistine Chapel ceiling bends almost double with paint splashing on his face
as he aged.
He wrote more poems of a religious nature throughout the reign of several pipes.
He held the position of chief architects of some peters.
Meanwhile,
he works on carvings that were variations of the work that had fast propels him
to fame,
the PSL.
It was while working on one of his pieces on February the twelfth,
15,
64 that he began to feel feverish you took to his bat,
and despite the efforts of his doctors,
he died six days later.
His dying wish was to have his body returned to Florence,
the city that he loved.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.